awaken battle grammar school teachers
suspended as parents processed
after image of prophet muhammad peace be
upon him shown in class
[Music]
but when it's muslims it's okay it's
fine and so
swear freedom of speech you believe in
freedom of speech
when it's the british flat don't you
dare when it's churchill you better not
when it's the french flag we will deal
with you
check out our sponsors nature's blends
they specialize in premium ethiopian
black seed products
the website is in the description link
below you can also use the discount code
salam 10 for 10 of their products
assalamu two brothers and sisters and
dear friends hope you guys are well
inshallah so as you guys might know and
not know but
in badly in dues brief i'm not mistaken
uh back in grammar school teachers
suspended as parents processed
after image of prophet muhammad peace be
upon him shown in class
now i came across this on twitter i was
actually going to go to the school then
i realized it's 256 miles away
and i thought i don't think i can do
that if it was local i definitely would
want to go
these things are very important to cover
because there is a mis big
misrepresentation by a lot of people and
a lot of people use this
as propaganda um and this is always
falls into the hands of the far right
or all other extreme groups whoever it
may be that's using it to their
advantage to
further uh propagate their propaganda so
a video that'll be coming out with me
and kanan robertson who was an
ex-employer of tommy robinson a
cameraman who
shared this experience how he left them
and he actually we did a reaction video
to him
where he had unedited footage of tommy
robinson punching an immigrant in the
face and we show how he provoked that
guy
in a footage coming out hopefully this
week maybe sunday inside which will be
an eye-opener
to how the far-right take advantage of
situations like this and that is exactly
what was happening on twitter
so yeah i came across this on twitter so
basically there was a woman called kate
saying this is the uk not an islamic
country if the parents do not like our
freedom
take your children to an islamic school
in an islamic country the head teacher
should
should withdraw his apology and the
parents investigated
now this is absolute hypocrisy let me
tell you guys why it is hypocrisy
this whole concept of freedom of speech
is it doesn't exist number one it
doesn't exist anywhere
for that matter brothers and sisters
yeah and people
take this opportunity they make it seem
as if islam is asking for
special rights it's time to say no no no
we are special
you you're not no what islam is saying
the damn rights that you have
we would like the same police thank you
very much then
if that was a muslim school if there was
a muslim school
burning flags insulting churchill or
talking this
i would be the same i would say the same
thing i would have the same sympathy
with the british public protesting out
there for that to change
its consistency and that is exactly what
we're asking for so let's not use this
false banner
of you know islam is attacking our
freedom of speech just dispute our
islamophobia
if you can't install that for example
i've done a video a couple of days ago
of two bbc presenters
who were ba who lost their jobs or
something along those lines
for merely saying talking about
criticizing the size of a
british flag in france and other places
for example there is many examples that
i can give you where people have lost
their job
of based on freedom of speech now this
is across board
cross-cultural yes international global
if you go to any specific country and
insult the president
or insult the flag or insult the
national anthem
or whatever it may be people are going
to be damned annoyed
yes okay if i get the british flag or
get churchill's picture
and start spitting at it or start
insulting it or start swearing at it
what do you think this this lady kate or
the far right or the british folk who
talking about freedom of speech and we
want special rights we don't want
special rights
what we're seeing is we would like it to
be consistent please
that's what we're asking so it's not
exclusive to islam
we're just asking just is that for
example i'll give you many examples
let's let go
my notes here i've got a note uh that i
got from one of sadhana resources speech
and i would like to read that to you
guys
there is no such thing as absolute
freedom of speech every society has
limits and restrictions on speech
david manville affinity's name is he
said the first thing to note in any
sensible discussion
of freedom of speech that it would have
to be limited every society puts limit
on exercise and speech
because it always takes place within a
context of competing values
french criminal code punish punishes
outrage or insult on the anthem and flag
so are we going to criticize france and
be like you know why don't you allow us
to insult the flag or the national
anthem
no we're not we're going to respect that
okay we won't even call it patriotic
yeah
the the political cartoonist maurice
sinai sinai
sinai i think he worked for charlie
hebdo for 20 years
and he was sacked in 2009 for drawing
cartoons mocking the former french
president's sons
with a wealthy jewish woman anti-semitic
no freedom of speech there a french
court ban a jesus-based clothing advert
mimicking
davinci's last supper french judge wrote
the display is an aggressive act of an
intrusion on people's innermost beliefs
bravo really but when it's muslims
it's okay it's fine and so swear
freedom of speech you believe in freedom
of speech when it's the british flat
don't you dare when it's churchill you
better not when it's the french flag
we will deal with you when it's
jesus or whatever it may be christians
or jews
you get fired yeah but when it's muslim
it's freedom of speech you see the
absolute damn
hypocrisy and that's why people like
kenan robertson
see this and saw what the five right was
coming with and this woman kate
yeah and i believe she's ignorant you
know i just believe her i don't have any
kind of hate towards me she's
ignorant let's carry on classically
historically freedom of speech was
understood to be
means of it means to achieve important
virtues such as true
truth progress accountability especially
those in
power those in power british philosopher
john stuart mill said
freedom of speech forces authenticity
genius creativity
in the individuality and human
flourishing
there is no logical connection between
freedom to insult and these virtues
number one
to convince someone of the truth in many
circumstances require argumentation
persuasion and civility talking in
manners not insulting one another how do
i expect you to listen to me when i'm
insulting you or someone that's near to
you
number two insults insults in many
contexts are a barrier towards good
argumentation
persuasion and civility so insulting
using freedom of speech goes against
your own objective you're shooting
yourself in the foot and thirdly
therefore insults in many cases prevent
the truth therefore the objective of
freedom of speech is undermined
brothers and sisters what i'm just
saying in a nutshell is that as you can
see
that people are protesting yeah let's
quickly just
have a look at that hopefully yeah
[Music]
so as you guys saw there people are
protesting and they're outraged
this is not a muslim issue we're not
saying to you as muslims
we want a special right like i said
before they're upset and they have a
right to
if i did the same i would expect the
same thing if i said
my my i want to use my freedom of speech
um as a muslim to praise the
gangs the grooming gangs for example who
actually got enough to do with islam but
for argument's sake if i said
i want to go and tell them that what
they did was right if i use my freedom
of speech to criticize
the girls rather than criticizing the
perpetrators who did that to these
girls what do you think will happen to
me do you think the far right
of people will come and say to me you
know what ali we disagree what you're
saying
like you know um one philosopher said
i've got his name
he said you know i i despise what you
say but i'll defend to death you're
right to say it yeah even though i
believe that's not really
accurate you know people would be losing
their minds
and rightly so because this is wrong i
can't just say no freedom of speech this
is nonsense
that's why i'm saying guys in a nutshell
that this teacher
thinks that him going and drawing the
the first peace before his cartoons
and showing it to the public he's it's
it's actually a protest that what this
guy's doing he's saying
you guys are stopping our freedom of
speech and i believe he's ignorant he
needs to be educated
yeah i believe he needs to be educated
this guy is brainwashed
so you need to be educated and if you're
watching this video for god's sake
what we don't want extra special um uh
we don't want special treatment for us
yeah
for example if you talk about israel in
america you're not even allowed to down
boycott them
you're not allowed to boycott them if
you talk about israel it's anti-semitism
what they're doing to the palestinians
if there's anyone that's having special
rights here it's israel
if anybody so guys uh for those who are
there the parents the children they have
a right to be disturbed they have a
damn right to be protesting i'll end on
that no brothers and sisters
hope you guys have benefited till next
time share this with your friends and
family let's show the double standards
and hypocrisy of these people
when it's their flag when it's their
country whether it's their leader
churchill whoever it may be or boris
johnson or donald trump they lose their
mind
but when is us no you have to accept it
get the hell out of here boys and girls
goodbye